if you are planning to be a cyber
security professional and a security
Operation Center these are some of the
tools you might be using I'm going to do
an acronym Bingo of three of them think
of sim or security information and event
management as a security guard for your
digital world it detects threats before
they affect your businesses by gathering
logs from every device and security
tools Sim promptly alerts you to any
looming dangers imagine EDR also known
as endpoint detection and response as
your computer's personal detectives it
safeguards your computers from Advanced
cyber attacks that bypass traditional
security it continuously monitors all
end points detects threats in real time
and autor responds to prevent damage s
also known as security orchestration
Automation and response is like the
brain of a modern cyber security a
streamlined cyber security with
intelligent automation boosting response
efficiency it intelligently connects
tools and ensures Swift action against
threats so how many of them did you get